我覺得大環境
我們面對的是一樣的事情
例如說講說
對不對
對
但我覺得
因為你回家很累
你隨便刷一刷
你就很容易買東西進來啊
真的
就是我們事實上是用一個
然後我們工時這麼長
你的確需要疏壓的方法啊
所以它其實是
很多大環境結合下來
然後讓我們
東西這麼多
所以我們事實上是用自己
小小意志力在處理這件事情
所以我覺得
不需要苛責自己耶
我們自己真的已經
很厲害了
這只是故事的一小段
如果想要看到完整內容的話
記得點擊右上角的連結
嗨 大家好
我是雯心醫師
歡迎收看女人療心室
我們今天邀請到的是
慢捨離
這本書的作者
黃惠如老師
那我們要跟老師
一起來釐清一件事情
什麼東西
才是真正我們想要留下的
而什麼東西
其實可以放下呢
讓我們歡迎老師
黃惠如老師
謝謝
雯心醫師好
各位觀眾朋友大家好
那因為我其實本身呢
追蹤老師很久了
然後我很喜歡這本書的一個點是
就是我以前看那些收納書
我都有一種覺得
好
我看完了
我要很有動力的
我就是
今天要把它清潔完畢這樣子
或者我怎麼幾天內
我就要整理完
但是這本書就是讓我有一種就是
然後我可以
我真的是從看這本書
大概應該有
反正這幾個月啦
我目前都在執行這樣的事情
對
然後我小孩有看到我的變化
媽媽家裡有變得比較乾淨
然後在看書的時候
我也不斷地一直想到
這個其實跟調整飲食
調整體態
養身體
我覺得都有很多很類似的概念
跟慢老
其實是一樣
所以其實空間跟環境
也都是一樣的道理
是啊
都是無間地獄
你如果沒有找到
一個適合自己的
可以長期持之運作的
一個系統的話
它就是一定就是會再重複
過去的路又再走回去
而且我最喜歡有一個點
其實真的有
還有打到我的一件事情
就是那個瑞典死亡整理
這個很多人都有
對
我認識的一個吳映蓉博士
她是我的好朋友
哦
然後她看了
她最打動她也是這一段
然後她就規定自己
然後這本書還給她老公看
她老公也是一個醫生
然後他還會跟那個吳博士說
你的那五個quota給我
哈哈哈
我要丟多一點
我今天要丟10個東西
對呀
他們兩個看了這本書
之後就很努力的丟
簡單講那本
東方比較不談死亡
所以對這件事情
就談得比較少
但是我們在國際上看到
很多人
在處理父母的遺物的時候
反而是成年子女很大的創傷
對
就是你滿屋子的東西
你根本不知道哪些東西
對你父母而言是珍貴的
然後你要一個一個翻開
然後一個個確定到底
要不要處理
紐約時報有一對姐弟
他們投書他們的狀態
他們花了六個禮拜
還請年假
丟丟丟丟
丟丟丟丟丟丟丟
還丟不完
還去租倉庫把東西放進去
所以你本來對父母的
那些懷念、哀傷
現在反而變成了一個
阿雜的心情
真的好矛盾哦
我應該要很悲傷的
可是我怎麼又有點
生氣的感覺呢
對
有一種愛叫作
自己的東西自己丟
就是你不要
讓你的子女去處理這件事
一開始就說
難道你恨你的子女嗎
或是你恨你的遺囑執行人嗎
除非是這樣子
你才把這麼多東西
這麼多雜物留給他們
真的
我覺得這個好打到我
好強烈
而且是在
有小孩以後
哇
那個感受更加的深刻
我就想說
天阿
我不想我的孩子面對這些東西
但我更想到的事情是
如果我跟父母的關係很好
我會非常明確的知道
他捨不得這些東西
那我就更不敢丟了
而且我都可以想到我
丟這個東西的時候
可能我的父母會講什麼
那是多大的一個
真的
對
所以我在看的時候
其實真的非常有感觸
老師有覺得
就是在寫書的過程中
或是您的讀者的回饋
覺得大家最難丟的是什麼
或是最難放下的是什麼
東西本來就很難丟啊
因為東西從來都不只是東西
是你的審美
你的情感
你的記憶
甚至就是你人生的一部分
例如照片
禮物
然後日記
還有人生高光時刻的
例如說我以前得過很多那個
最佳拚戰獎的員工的獎牌
所以好奇老師在寫書的過程中
有覺得自己已經可以
放下這些執著了嗎
我說實話
我日記也丟了
然後我那些獎牌也丟了
你一定覺得很難想象
就是我的小說很多
從我大學時代一直到現在
我搬過無數次家
它都要跟著我走欸
我從來都沒有想過要丟過他們
因為你會覺得在你
人生很灰暗的時刻
它們照亮了你
但是我直到最近最後一次搬家
我突然感覺到
它們對我來講不是甜蜜的記憶
反而是一個很沈重的負擔
因為我真的每次光小說就要好幾箱
然後我就覺得我真的
一定要一直搬著它嗎
後來就是有個機會
看到我的好朋友
他說他後來就是
把小說都處理掉
如果真的還想再讀
就再買一本就好
就表示你真心需要
或是喜歡那本書
然後
然後這件事情就解放了我欸
其實很多人都會問我說
萬一又需要它怎麼樣
其實我們很多東西
都會遇到這個萬一症候群
就是你可能
一大堆的毛巾都放在那
然後你都會覺得
萬一有朋友來我家住怎麼辦
萬一有親戚來怎麼辦
可是你
沒有要處理的時候
這個萬一症候群都不會出現
然後等你要處理的時候
就會出現
其實你要允許自己
偶爾會犯錯啊
就是犯錯就是
這個東西丟錯了
但是表示你真的喜歡它
那你就把它買回來
好好的珍惜它就好了
我覺得這好重要哦
因為我剛剛也在想到事情是
就是有時候會那個萬一
然後跟我這樣是不是浪費了
就有時候覺得說
可是我買了都沒有用到
這樣很浪費
所以我丟了就是承認
我花錯錢了
對
而且承認自己是一個浪費的人
很多人都是
不丟不丟不丟不丟
我最近上一個通告哦
然後他就說他爸爸
的那個保健食品都過期了
就算10年前的他都留著
他說因為至少可以餵鴿子
蛤
因為你如果讓它還有用
你就不是一個浪費的人
就是人很難去面對自己說是
一個浪費的人的那個定位
對
它其實是一個長的過程
所以才是一個慢捨離
當然還是會復亂
因為那個空間是在使用的嘛
對
就只要使用中
它是動態使用的
就一定會復亂
但是我就是有一個
就是你管理你的家
就跟管理一家公司是一樣的意思
例如說
我會建議大家就是
每天給自己十五分鐘
四首歌的時間
連多一分鐘都不要哦
就放音樂哦
真的哦
因為你多一分鐘
就覺得整理
整理很苦了
你不要想說
換季了我要收衣櫃
不要給自己這麼大壓力好不好
你就想說我今天收
內衣類
或是說襯衫類
就算廚房也是哦
你不要說我今天要清廚房
乾嘛給自己這麼大壓力
你只要說我今天清水槽
擦乾淨
十五分鐘應該就可以
然後你把它弄得乾乾淨淨的
去喝杯好的咖啡
明天再換一個地方
後天再換一個地方
等等的
例如說現在換季
我也又開始拿一些東西出來丟啊
那就會有一些衣服開始不能穿
但是你又覺得它
在Outlet買其實蠻貴的
對
就是又是那種
不行不能浪費
我這本書還有另外一個
核心概念叫
就是你給自己說
也許可以
放手
但是我現在還不確定
就是你給自己三個月啊
或者六個月的時間
標上日期哦
那你就可以先放在那邊
但是你放在那邊經過三個月
六個月之後發現
你的確都沒有
打開過它
你真的不需要它
而且你的衣櫥少了它之後
你很喜歡那個清爽的感覺
那你就可以真心的跟它說
再見
任何東西都可以
我覺得其實聊到女人療心室
當初這個Podcast
其實因為自己女生
然後也覺得女生在社會中
其實蠻多的挑戰的
所以其實也想要問老師說
您覺得我們
女人在不同的人生階段
其實捨離的重點
可能會不一樣
那現在50歲的您
回頭看30歲的時候
你覺得最想放下的是什麼
我其實在30歲的時候曾經
留職停薪到紐約去
到了30
我還是覺得自己一事無成欸
啊
然後覺得什麼都不是
30歲
對
然後那時候就很惶恐
所以我就留職停薪
到了紐約去
那我現在會想跟那時候講說
其實不用再太在意外界的標準
也不用對世俗名利有太多的追求
因為你到50歲的時候
哈哈哈
是莫名其妙的嗎
沒有什麼東西讓你突然覺得
有沒有什麼點
讓你覺得說
我不要了
我這些東西我要放掉了
其實我是被離職的
我雖然是總編輯
但是那時候遇到
比較大數位的挑戰
然後整個團隊對這件事情
不覺得我是一個
可以帶領大家去面對
新挑戰的總編輯啦
所以
其實媒體壓力
是工作壓力很大的
那我是常年的肩頸痠痛
是痠痛到
我記得有一年
有那個超級月亮
然後我們也擁有比較多的
醫學的資源
醫療資源
所以我什麼
中醫
西醫啊
然後另類的啊
我都試過
然後通常就是在診間的時候
我這樣講
可能會得罪很多人
就突然在診間的時候有效
對
然後走出去
其實是不是他醫術的問題
是你的壓力沒有改變
所以你回來沒多久
可能又會開始痛起來
所以是
你好厲害
因為我本來寫就是寫這樣子
對呀
聽起來真的是身體在告訴你
非走不可
有些東西可能
不是你可以承受的
對對對
我自己身為醫生
臨床上我真的也看到很多這樣子
這其實也是這個
節目某一種程度的目的
因為我覺得有時候是
對於自己的狀態沒有覺察
然後是反應在身體上
因為沒有任何人會
因為肩頸酸痛不做總編輯
Got it
太對了
對
所以
捨去什麼
就是有沒有辦法把它放開這件事情
對很多人來說
都是一個很大的挑戰
對
不過我最近
剛好訪問了鐘穎老師
他就是研究榮格嘛
他就說我們中年之後
會回到找自己阿
的那個英雄之旅
但往往都是不得不
並不是我們
有多大的勇氣
但我覺得
所謂的不得不啊
通常是踩在我們
比較痛
或者比較在意的點上面
但也因為夠痛
我們才願意去面對這些東西
當我們不再執著過去啊
腳步開始慢下來的時候
聽起來老師覺得自己的很大
一個變化就是
不要管別人的眼光
做自己嗎
你覺得
在這個社會上嘛
其實你就算不在組織裡
你還是會受市場的影響
就算你不在組織裡做雜誌
你出書你還是會受排行榜的影響
但是你要想說
你能做的就是你自己把它做好
但是你不能控制的東西
你要放手
然後你要珍惜自己所有的努力
我覺得珍惜自己好重要哦
因為剛好講到50歲這個階段啦
我發現
可能也真的是
讓我們越來越能專注在就是
我過去的那些應該怎麼做
是我真的覺得這樣很重要嗎
還是我是被某一些
信念或是限制性的想法
給綁架了而不自知
所以我都覺得那個主軸
中心點
因為很多人會捨不得
或是無法丟
都是看到的是物品
就是你的主詞變成物品
就是像飲食運動
生活習慣其實都是一樣的
是別人說這個食物不好
那我自己吃這個食物的感受
是怎麼樣
它真的有那麼不好嗎
還是在某些情境來講
其實我跟食物這樣子
的關係其實是很好
是啊是啊
其實是一樣的事情
真的真的
好
那我覺得就是
今天看這集的觀眾朋友
還不一定有看這個書
如果他現在聽了這樣
他正在迷惘
覺得說好
我打算現在踏出第一步
那老師有沒有給這樣子的人一個建議
就是第一步馬上就可以先做什麼
我通常會建議大家從
並不是客人比你重要
就是你如果
哦 我現在要丟
你馬上去拿
打開一個抽屜
或者是哪一個
儲藏室
在那邊收收收了老半天
但是等於
沒感覺啊
講的太對了
所以你要從打開你的門
你看到玄關
是不是有一些用過的那個口罩啊
或是廣告信啊
是不是看著有點阿雜
就先丟
成就感這三個字不斷的出現
我覺得好重要
我現在突然想到上禮拜
讓我好氣哦
就是一個朋友很久沒來我家了
然後這樣一開門
因為他跟我很熟
他說 哇
你們家真的亂到不行
我說怎麼會
我最近看了慢捨離
我已經收了很多地方了
講到對了
因為我就是收那個裡面的
就是裡面的那些櫃子
其實都已經很乾淨了
真心覺得大家不要去
一開始就
面對讓你淚眼汪汪的東西哦
就是你要打開抽屜
這是小孩子3歲的時候
做的那個母親卡
這是當年寫的日記
這是以前誰的留下的情書
幹嘛
就是你整理3分鐘而已
在那邊回憶3小時
卡住了
完全卡住
你真的要比較理性一點的
從客人視角開始丟
通常會比較
看到效果有成就感
是
因為現在這麼多書在講多巴胺
我們真的就要利用這個多巴胺阿
因為沒有人喜歡整理
沒有人喜歡做家事
講了五萬遍
沒有人喜歡飲控
對對對
因為很多人都會說
我天生不擅長整理
但是我們都
讀過暢銷書原子習慣
對不對
對
裡面最重要的一句就說
你們減重也是
其實也是
對
但是你要想說
其實就是
我可以
我做得到
對
而不是再買更多的
傢具跟收納櫃來塞它們
對
沒錯
我跟你說
我這次上了很多通告
有些是一個老朋友
他們就說
惠如
我印象中你不是賢惠的人
哈哈哈
沒有想到你能出這樣的書
所以我做得到
你們也做得到
太棒了
有我們兩個在這邊鼓勵大家
大家一定都可以了
這個年好過了
沒有問題
節目進展到尾聲
其實我們節目有個特色
就是我會給
來賓聞精油啦
因為我其實覺得就是
精油這個東西
它的香味
它其實很直接的透過嗅覺
可以連接我們的一個
神經傳導路徑
還有大腦的一個系統
那有時候我們對於身體的狀況啊
甚至心理的
覺察不夠的時候
那聽說老師
也是很喜歡香味的人
對
那我們就請老師
我們看我們這邊已經
有三支點好的精油
所以我是都去聞它的香味
然後選一個我喜歡的味道嗎
是的是的
這個好了
哦
好
其實我用香氣
也會按照我的狀態
就是我白天的話就會
比較是那個柑橘類的東西
會讓我精神比較好
然後我這個就有點接近
我的家的味道
果然老師的嗅覺
非常的敏銳
那甜橙就是
很經典的柑橘類精油
那甜橙這個東西
它不像葡萄柚那麼刺激
有時候我們現代人
已經太交感了
就是自律神經
已經過Hyper的時候
用葡萄有時候會太過振奮
但是甜橙它就會比較溫順
比較溫暖和煦一點
就比較剛好這樣子
那或者是說近期也許有一些腸胃啦
或是心理的一些鬱悶
然後就會覺得這支精油很適合
對啊
就是我真的覺得精油
有時候不太需要背很多的原理
好像就是自己聞到覺得
今天也不知道怎麼就覺得
這個味道特別有feel的時候
可能它剛好
就是對我們有幫助
那我自己也有經驗就是
特別討厭某種味道的時候
有時候呢
可能是呈現你的
譬如說陰影面
或是比較放不下的某些地方
這樣子
這個其實是我平常自己的
算是一種養心秘訣啦
那老師自己
有沒有什麼養心秘訣呢
我自己會建議大家
或我自己會做的事情
哦
就是這個呼吸法叫作
在研究中
是發現對負面情緒
還有焦慮
比冥想都有效
然後我自己會發現有
心跳會有點快的時候
我會自己做一點點這樣的練習
哇哦
很實用
其實你只要練個兩三次
你心情就會覺得比較平靜
我剛想到如果搭上精油的話
有時候剛好那個香氣也
趁著這個機會進去的話
對
很棒
好像也還蠻不錯的
最後
如果觀眾今天只記住
老師您的一句話的話
你最想留給我們觀眾什麼
就是在這個世界呢
你會需要一個粉絲
無論你多爛、多糟
他都會支持你
我好喜歡這句
太棒了
那我覺得我們的身體和空間啊
其實都是在反映
我們自己內心的狀態
重要的其實不是
怎麼整理
或是擁有一個多舒適、乾淨的地方
而是你有沒有準備好
真的讓自己值得活出
自己最真實最好的樣子
而不是拘泥在過去
或是執著於過去那些
我們的放不下和捨不得
今天看完這一集
希望所有的觀眾朋友
都可以跟我們一樣
重新迎來
更好好生活
好好呼吸的
屬於你自己的空間
謝謝黃惠如老師
也謝謝各位觀眾朋友
喜歡我們的節目的話
記得訂閱、按讚加分享
下次再見囉
拜拜